la dernier qui comme 4% des français a
déjà fait l'amour dans un ascenseur et
une fois le lieu le plus insolite en
tout cas un beau sens moi c'était voyez
les a tous fait celui-ci a une vie de
vieux théâtre à l'italienne comme ça
allait
c'était dans une loge sur le ce qu'on
appelle une baignoire c'est des trucs
qui sont presque en à pic sur la scène
ah ouais mais il y avait les vivats du
public
j'adore boivent ou pas dans un monde
char à boeufs
des travaux quoi est donc ouais alors
moribond monte charge pour une décharge
c'est logique
merci vous avez fait on s'en sort entre
les deux étages
ouvrez les portes ça coinçait
l'ascenseur et deux étages du coup tu
avais plus de tente et est peinard et
votre fille s'appelle otis une fois
aussi mais c'est facile choix s'est
bloqué quatre heures la sanction est
tombée en panne
vous avez quatre heures devant moi la
connaissez la personne âgée peut seul
[Rires]
je sais que 3d très pudique
oui mais moi je suis jaloux ils font des
stages des monte-charges moi tout ça
dans ma vie mais elle est magnifique
votre histoire vous un autre histoire
d'amour ouais c'est cool ça s'passe
j'adore jeune j'aime beaucoup christine
vous moi c'était aussi ça avait touché 3
millions d'euros les dépenses est
décevant mais ils ont l'âge de mon père
adacore ouais quand même
non mais j'ai rencontré mon mari dans un
avion la dimension depuis mai on l'a
dans un avion ah oui mais voilà on a
toujours été très correct dans les
avions c'était le patron de la compagnie
aérienne ou non mariés et donc mais vous
avez mais oui mais quel rapport il ya eu
un bail dans l'avion on s'est quand même
abstenue d'avoir un bail berne alors
l'horreur en fait alors je ne compte
jamais le lien entre la question
précédente et cette question quand on
s'est rencontrés dans un avion mais s'il
était patron de la compagnie aérienne
ont ces épouses et mères et à beinheim
qui fait ben moi j'ai fait un truc de
ouf
un jour on a fait ça sur des lits
superposés alors venez yves barboussat
doigté magique voit la voiture les
maximums atteints belime voiture au
maximum
mais attention attention si c'est un
diesel limousine stretch à new york
c'est à dire dimanche la whey ses
classes avec une limousine chirac hier
oui avec une sombre une chambre à
coucher derrière abbas était à new york
cette équipe parce que le gars qui a une
limousine stretch en fait si je faisais
un défilé de mode à l'époque et la
mannequin qui était sous contrat avec en
mars qu'il avait beaucoup d'argent et de
la marque l'avait offert 7
on voit on n'a pas la même
c'est dans une opel kadett toute option
hd elle est allée était très romantique
en fait donc les gens vous voient pas
vous citer dans une cabine à uv
j'étais en train de réfléchir à
l'endroit de solides n'ont pas vraiment
battre avec moi d'en bas merci bon et
intéressant
on essaie de saper tout est important
qu'on se parle quand même oui ah bah oui
faut que j'avais oublié ce que ça aurait
pu ne pas y aurait pu ne pas vendre
droit solide mais j'aimerais du coup
remercier face à lui et british airways
je veux pas citer une marque mais par
rapport à l'or va quitter demain sur
d'autres aires frange hardcore ici avec
vous mais j'ai pris l'avion donc sur
cette marque là cette compagnie naje
j'ai très très peur en avion et du coup
très gentiment je connaissais pas un
stewart n'avait proposé commencé le
matin et comment supportez-vous
commandes vont donc le gars passe
[Rires]
karimi les cachalots ont pu
tranquillement tant mieux s'il vous
plaît monsieur créés s'annulent atom
jure que c'est vrai n'ont pas dit non
mais c'est un avion km à 10h oui dans un
petit théâtre parisien voir sur ces
quelques intérieurs fermé c'était fermé
c'était quelqu'un qui sait quoi parce
que j'ai longtemps c'était mon petit ami
de l'époque comme ces chenilles se
réveille t il paraît qu'on l'appelait le
point virgule mais non mais lui ça mais
il peut faire un guide un sans rigoler